en tiempos normales en este cementerio
no se verían tumbas esperando ataúdes o
sepulturas sin identificar pero aquí
están esta es la realidad en la parte
nueva del cementerio militar de crans no
priva de ni pero desde que comenzó la
guerra en ucrania
varios días a la semana a micael lysenko
vicealcalde de ni pero recibe
información de las morgues donde se
acumulan los cuerpos de los soldados
muertos en la guerra pero algunos
cuerpos no son fáciles de identificar y
les tomamos el adn y cuando las familias
nos lo piden lo comparamos
para determinar de dónde es el soldado y
quiénes son sus allegados y
dice que aún hoy no hay investigaciones
independientes que lo corroboren lysenko
dice que también hay cuerpos de soldados
rusos muertos en localidades como dones
jarquín y lugansk nos lleva hasta el
camión frigorífico donde los han
colocado y permite que los veamos pero
no lograremos no podemos y
estas informaciones no pueden ser
difundidas en base a las leyes
ucranianas y has visto que en las bolsas
con los nombres y apellidos no queremos
hacer daño a sus parientes y que se
enteren de su muerte a través de un
reportaje
en la guerra de ucrania ni la muerte
tiene tregua